la situation dans le haut-karabagh au
coeur des échanges ce matin entre le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
et son homologue arménien à moscou les
deux hommes ont tenu une conférence de
presse il ya une heure pour en parler
notre correspondant à moscou
antoine clients dans un premier temps
sergueï lavrov a déclaré que dès le
début des hostilités
la russie a tout fait pour favoriser la
désescalade de la situation dans le haut
karabakh
cela s'est traduit par la hausse de la
fréquence des échanges et cela au plus
haut niveau ce qui a pu se traduire par
la conclusion d'un cessez le feu dans la
nuit du 9 au 10 octobre
et maintenant que faire s'assurer du
respect de la trêve et bien sûr
continuer à négocier notamment dans le
cadre du groupe de minsk le 9 et le 10
octobre vous y avaient assisté peut-être
nous avons tenu une rencontre qui a
permis d'obtenir des ententes qui ont
été publiés diffusé dans le nu est
d'enlever ce et nous espérons que cette
trêve serait respectée par toutes les
parties
nous sommes échangés sur les démarches à
suivre ensuite cela ne veut dire ne veut
pas dire que toutes les questions seront
réglées tout de suite
nous comprenons très bien que cela
prendra du temps mais bien sûr faut pas
traîner
il faut continuer les négociations et
comme nos amis arménien âge nous ont
informés dans le cadre du ministre note
sakania on va progresser lors de la
rencontre avec les représentants du
groupe de minsk heures c'est ensuite son
homologue arménien qui a pris la parole
il a dit apprécier les efforts de la
russie dans la résolution du conflit du
haut karabakh pour lui depuis le 27
septembre l'arménie est la cible d'une
agression de la part de l'azerbaïdjan
qui frappe je cite sans faire de
distinction entre cibles civiles et
militaires
le ministre arménien hak us back ou de
ne pas respecter le cessez-le-feu
et dénonce le rôle de la turquie dans ce
conflit
le peuple du haut karabakh fait face à
cette menace depuis 30 ans cette menace
s'aggrave par deux facteurs négatifs
à cette étape notamment c'est
l'implication directe de la turquie et
des militants venant de la syrie de la
libye terroristes des radicaux utilisent
sont utilisés par la turquie pour
exporter son enfant atteint les régions
dans son entourage
c'est un fait prouvé que des militaires
ont été transférés par la turquie et
cela a été évoqué par la communauté
internationale en recourant aux services
des terroristes est sûr qu le haut
karabakh est devenu le centre de
terrorisme international dans notre
région cette politique de se tenir les
organisations terroristes de leur offrir
des couloirs dans le caucase et pourrait
donner lieu à une exclusion d'activités
terroristes non seulement de notre
région mais également à ses alentours
sergey lavrov a dit avoir été en contact
avec son homologue turc qui lui a assuré
le soutien de la turquie aux accords de
moscou entre l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
cependant les ministres russe et
arménien ont chacun leur tour réitéré la
pertinence du format du groupe de minsk
c'est à dire avec la participation de
représentants de la france des
etats-unis et de la russie
seul format qui à leurs yeux est capable
de ramener la paix et c'est d'ailleurs
de cette façon qu'a conclu le ministre
arménien des affaires étrangères
il n'y a pas d'alternative à une
résolution pacifique de ce conflit